the new panties are work in another EU
or European Economic Area country and
can leave back at least once a week to
your country of residence if you are and
what will happen to your social security
coverage social security coverage
includes your health care your maternity
or paternity family and unemployment
benefits and your pension rights only
one country is responsible for your
social security coverage at a time
usually the one where you work and pay
your social security contributions
Michael's an engineer he lives in
Belgium but commutes daily to his
workplace in the Netherlands so the
Netherlands where he pays his
contributions is responsible for his
social security coverage as a frontier
worker Michael can receive health care
both in the Netherlands and in Belgium
in Belgium Michael just has to request
an s-1 form from the Dutch Health Care
authority he can then use this to
register for health care in Belgium when
Michael uses health care services at
home the Netherlands will reimburse
Belgium behind the scenes but what
happens if Michael loses his job as a
frontier worker he will have to register
with the Employment Services and claim
unemployment benefits in his country of
residence in this case Belgium and not
in the country where he was working and
paying contributions the Belgian
employment services then decide on his
claim according to the Belgium rules
they will take into account the last
salary Michael earned in the Netherlands
and if necessary
Nereus of insurance employment or
self-employment Michael has in any EU
country plus Iceland Liechtenstein
Norway or Switzerland Michael will need
a portable document new one from the
Dutch authorities to confirm these
periods of insurance the Netherlands
will reimburse Belgium partly for the
unemployment benefits provided on its
behalf
Michael must register with the Belgian
employment services but in order to
increase his chances of finding
employment he may also choose to
register as a person see
employment with the Dutch employment
services the Belgian job seeking
activities for her priority since
Belgium is now responsible for his
Social Security including health care
family benefits and his unemployment
benefits
thanks to EU Social Security
coordination you can move freely around
Europe and not lose out on your Social
Security rights
[Music]